These giant tech companies have
so much power,
Big Tech poses the single
greatest threat to free speech
in our country today.
So much economic power
and so much political power.
Everywhere you turn these days, big
tech companies are under fire.
Instagram supposedly addictive
and negative effects on teenage
girls have lawmakers comparing its
parent company, Facebook, to
Big Tobacco.
Conservatives like Florida Gov.
Ron DeSantis and Texas Gov.
Greg Abbott have signed
controversial legislation banning
social media platforms from
moderating content and kicking off
users for political reasons.
Supreme Court Associate Justice
Clarence Thomas has said businesses
like
Twitter and YouTube should be subject to strict federal regulation. Liberal legislators in Colorado have proposed creating a digital communications commission that would have the power to change how platforms do business in the name of fighting hate speech and misinformation. Lawmakers in at least 38 states have introduced over 100 laws in the past couple of years to regulate online speech and business practices. In his new book, "Tech Panic," Reason's, Robby Soave says such attacks are modern
day witch hunts that fall apart
under even mild scrutiny.
They're, the contemporary version of
past freak outs over video
games, rock music and comic books.
We shouldn't fear Facebook or the
future, writes Soave, the actual
threat, he says, comes not from
private companies, but from
politicians, woke mobs,
social conservatives and activists
whose real goal is to limit speech
they don't like.
Robby Soave, thanks for talking.
My pleasure.
Give me the elevator pitch
of "Tech Panic.
Why We Shouldn't Fear Facebook
and the Future."
Sure. Panic about social media
is very popular right now.
It's bipartisan.
It's across all over the ideological
spectrum.
People as different as Elizabeth
Warren and Josh Hawley and Joe Biden
and Donald Trump all think we need
to do something. The government
needs to do something about social
media, about Big Tech.
My book argues, No, that's wrong.
The concerns are overstated.
The solutions that these people
offer are very bad, don't
the.. From a range of not fixing
the problems that they're talking
about to they'll
make things worse to the problems
they're talking about aren't even
problems. So I get into
all the various the most popular
panics about social media and
discuss to the extent they're true
and what should be done about them.
OK, so we'll go through them
and we're going to come to things
like Section 230 and antitrust
actions against,
you know, Big Tech.
But first, you know, the kind of
panic de de jour
which came up after in a big
way after the book was was
printed has to do with Facebook
and Instagram having
a terrible negative effect,
particularly on young girls.
This this Instagram report
came out.
The Wall Street Journal talked it up
about Instagram and
Facebook researchers had looked at
the platform itself
and said, Oh my God, you know,
Instagram is driving young girls,
you know, to anorexia and worse.
What is wrong about that?
Right, so it looks to
me like Facebook
has come up with some internal data
showing a mild
increase in
in feelings of depression
or not being good enough or not
being pretty enough among teen
teenage girls.
I think their figure was a third of
their teenage female
users or experiencing heightened
depression because of Instagram, the
idea being that Instagram is showing
you more into the search feature.
It's showing you, you know, it's
curating for you a feed of images
based on things you've been
interested in, so you can see more
make up more models, more pretty
people. Also, Instagram itself
is this kind of deceptive medium
where you're seeing the the best,
the most glamorous, the most
attractive version of of everyone.
And that can lead to feelings of
of insecurity about your own
appearance, et cetera.
So I think from looking at and I
looked at a lot of other data for
this book.
If you want to say there are reasons
to be, we should be concerned we
should keep studying this.
It might be having a negative effect
on some teenagers.
Absolutely. I think that could
very well be the case, and we should
continue to look at these things.
The the idea that there's some
broad like
insurmountable problem for
the vast majority of social media
users does not seem well-founded.
You know, you can and you can cherry
pick this data. A lot of ways.
For every statistic
about how teenage
girls have become more
anxious or more unhappy
in the last 10 years, you can find
one showing that, well, this other
category of social media user
hasn't.
You know, it's really hard to
measure these things.
And also it looks
the some of the data looks to me
like the users
who who use social media.
Too much or extreme
all day have some bad mental health
outcomes. But so do the teens who
don't use social media at all.
The ones who are not, who are loners
who are not connected with their
friends.
So I mean, part of the concept
of the book and you know, it's in
the title tech panic is,
I mean, social media has become
kind of like the garbage bin that we
dump all of our anxieties and about
everything that is kind of going
wrong right now, right?
Yeah. And you know, if you think
about it in terms of it's
just like any, there's some
comparisons to remember video game
panic over violent video games.
And then it turned out that a lot of
preliminary research or even
assumptions and even research that
that video games were going to make
kids teenage boys more violent
didn't pan out.
In fact, it might even be true that
for like the most at risk capable
of violence, young men, it might
even deter them from it because it's
an outlet other than engaging
in violence.
So I expect to see some of that.
But also, you know, you can still
say it's perfectly appropriate for
parents to limit the amount
of time their teenagers spend
on social media. I was only allowed
to play an hour of video games on
weeknights because left to my own
device when I was a kid, I would.
I would have played video games all
night long, but that was the rule
and that was a healthy rule, and I
think it's totally reasonable,
Jonathan Haidt, who is concerned
about this.
But he said that that's a practical
parental intervention requires
the government to do nothing
whatsoever, just take the
phones away from them.
Well, I guess, you know, before we
go to, you know, whether or not
there's a public policy
dimension here, it's a question of
in the 90s you were talking about
when video games really came online,
like high intensity
and like with good graphics video
games that also
coincided with cable TV
coming under real scrutiny.
This was the Clinton administration
and people like Janet Reno, the
attorney general, constantly
talking about that. One of the
findings was that kids
who watch like 10 hours of TV
a day had bad outcomes,
but it was not even clear that
it mattered what was on the screen.
It was more something is off
if you're using social media
or any media for that kind
of thing.
And if you if you stay up all night
looking at your phone just as you
stayed up all night doing anything,
you're going to be tired, you're
going to be more sluggish in school
the next day.
Lack of sleep correlates very
obviously with with bad
mental health outcomes and other
struggles you might go through.
So I absolutely agree if it's if
it's interrupting the sleep patterns
of young people, that's probably not
healthy for them. But that's not
even that's not really a problem
with the technology itself.
You write a lot about the book
in the book, about the documentary
"The Social Dilemma," which says,
you know, at various points, this
was a Netflix
documentary that showed that,
you know, social media is different.
It's not like anything in the past.
"What I want people to know is that
everything they're doing online is
being watched is being tracked every
single action you take is
carefully monitored and recorded.".
"A lot of people think Google is
just a search box, and Facebook is
the place to see what my friends are
doing, what they don't realize is
there's entire teams of engineers
whose job is to use your
psychology against you."
Scientists, psychologists,
you know, data scientists have
figured out ways to
hook you and addict you in that
Wall Street Journal story
about Instagram.
Towards the end, Jean Twangy, the
social psychologist, talks about how
this sounds a lot like R.J.
Reynolds, a tobacco company hiding
data you know about the
addictiveness of its product.
Can you engage that
a little bit? Is there something
uniquely addictive
and different about social media,
or is this the video
game panic?
The you know, the movie
panic in the 20s?
The novel panic in the early
19th century?
I mean, you know, how how
seriously should we take
the idea that now this is
categorically different because we
have scientists manipulating
us and giving us endorphin hits
right?
Because they're inflating their own
their own contributions to these
projects?
So it's it. I find it a little hard
to believe. I also think these
people, since they're so engaged
with the technology, these were the
people most likely to be addicted
to it, to be so online.
So of course, they're going to see
it as a problem. I mean, journalists
who spend and policy people who
spend all day on Twitter are,
you know, inveighing against Twitter
and all the harms it's causing.
But most people aren't on Twitter
all day, that's just you.
So it's it's one's own
like being addicted
to the to the technology is,
I think, causing the
policymaker, and concerned
group of people to be worried.
This is having the same effect on
everyone else when it's not.
I think probably there are aspects
of these technologies that
are addictive or can be addictive.
But even like gambling is
addictive, right for some people.
Some people shouldn't gamble.
You shouldn't go to the casino.
You'll bet your wedding ring.
You'll bet the farm, whatever.
You'll bet the rent money,
as Bill Bennett, who had
a gambling problem, talked about.
Right. But most people
can go to the casino, spend a little
bit of money, have a good night, go
home. So even so, most
of the society is not, I
don't think is vulnerable to this
kind of thing. So then what you're
going to you're going to regulate it
or legislate it because there's
a minority of people who
have some kind of struggle with
regulating their own internal use
and might have some mental health
outcome. That's bad.
That's that's now it's getting into
like a very far afield problem
In your discussion of some
of the ways in which people talk
about these as addictive or as
threats or, as, you know,
social media as controlling
its users, you
make reference to a book from the
50s called "The Hidden Persuaders"
by Vance Packard.
Could you summarize that and kind
of explain why that, you
know, is good to know about when
when you're thinking about today's
tech?
Yeah, this is the Mad Men era.
And Vance Packard had come out with
this book about subliminal
advertising, subliminal messages in
advertising and how
you know you're no longer you.
The consumer are no longer in charge
of what you're buying because
there's a there's a, you know, it's
being you're being manipulated
by some subliminal message
in in commercials and
in posters, et cetera.
And that advertising agencies have
avail themselves of psychologists
right depths, the depth boys.
I think they were called,
they'd hacked the human brain, just
like the people in The Social
Dilemma are saying now.
But of course, none of that was
true. Subliminal messaging
is a fiction actual
people who work in ads understood
that they didn't have that power.
Like, this is just this is a very
clearly made up moral panic.
So because we've gone down this road
so many times, we should be
like extremely cautious.
The social dilemma is very concerned
about what ads the companies
are. And they treat as nefarious
this process that is not necessarily
nefarious, that that the, you know,
these sites make money by selling
advertisements because they've
learned something about your habits
based on what you've clicked on.
It's actually better to see more
relevant advertisements, like
if I watch TV, I might
get an advertisement for a car I'm
not going to buy. I'm not in the
market for a car.
But, you know, on on Facebook, my
ads are targeted to my actual
interests.
This is not a defect and the product
is free for you. The social media
site is free for you because
they're they're monetizing it in
this way.
And so this was I mean, it used to
be talked about as junk mail, right?
Like junk mail, as mail you don't
want. And advertisers were wasting
tons of people's their money
and people's time by flooding
mailboxes with
stuff that they didn't care about.
I mean, your argument is essentially
that the sites, whether it's Hulu
serving up ads or other programs you
might watch or Amazon,
they're actually giving you stuff
that you might remotely be
interested in.
Yeah, which is better.
This is a this is a positive hack
to advertising that
the tech kind of phobia people
are treating as necessarily bad and
evil and sinister and scary, which
it isn't necessarily right.
Let's ease off that.
Well, you know, part of
and in various parts of tech
panic you talk about one of
these things is the story about
how you know, a kid.
You know, a happy go lucky boy,
you know, has a kid and he goes,
what? His watch is one or two
YouTube videos about kittens and
then about five videos.
And he's become part of Al Qaeda
or ISIS, right
Proud Boys/Al Qaeda
Yeah.
Talk about that trope
and why that's actually not
happening.
Yeah, it's just nonsense.
There's been a several of
good studies of this phenomenon
that I reference in the book,
but it looks like YouTube was aware
that there was a radicalization
problem at some point in particular.
And, you know,
they made tweaks to how the
algorithm recommends you stories,
but it appears to be the case.
The algorithm is much more likely
to recommend you, an extreme
person, more moderating
content than it is to recommend
you a moderate person, extreme
content that's going to slowly
radicalize you in some direction.
You're more likely to be guided
away from like Infowars
style conspiracy,
which is a good thing.
Yeah, I well, you know.
Well, yeah, look, we don't have to
make that judgment.
Yeah, I mean, I guess Infowars
is off of YouTube anyway, so.
And so then that goes into
a larger category
of discussion. So I have been very
critical in my writing at Reason and
other places of a lot of individual
moderation decisions that social
media sites make.
I take seriously the claim that
that social media is
aggressively moderating provocative
or right wing, or even sometimes
left wing content that falls
outside of a kind of normie,
centrist, mainstream media approved
view. What they've done with some of
the so-called COVID misinformation
is really has been really despicable
and a lot of ways and some other
topics, so I do not
deny that there is an issue there.
And people have been right to call
it out, but there's not a good
solution that's been put on the
table.
And also some so much of the bad
judgment calls that social media
makes seem to have been pushed on
them by our own government
or, or mainstream
media institutions that are
constantly demanding
more censorship or silencing.
So it isn't the fault with them,
not with social media?
Does that, you know,
how do you talk about or how do you
think about the
Twitter and Facebook both?
You know, either outright killing
spiking links to the
Hunter Biden story shortly before
the election last fall or
in the case of Facebook tamping
it down and then eventually kicking
Trump off, I guess.
Let's let's talk about blocking that
story at Twitter.
Like, why is that a bad thing
if in fact, and I know we both
agree that Twitter,
Facebook, et cetera, these are
private companies and they do have
broad rights to
moderate content as they see
fit.
Is it a problem that they, you know,
they said of the New York Post.
You know, no, we're not even letting
people link to that story.
I think it is a problem.
And they admitted it was a problem.
They they apologized.
They said they got that call wrong.
You know, they had their own kind of
internal spokespeople,
communications people saying, Yeah,
we're very concerned that this story
is misinformation,
you know, suggesting that it's kind
of that it's kind of a hoax.
Not even that its premise is wrong,
but that like the the information
supplied it about the laptop is not
is not real.
We now kind of all agree that it was
actual genuine information
so that they were wrong to do that
and they said as much.
So I think it was a it was
a black eye on those companies.
They they shouldn't do that.
They said. They said they don't do
that. They don't want to do that.
I don't think claims that.
But then you'll hear from the right
that, oh yeah, we lost.
Trump lost the election because of
this. That's just so stupid.
I don't think anyone really believes
that do that. I mean, there was
a Streisand effect going on here
anyway that the D
that punishing the story made it
so that more people were talking
about it and sharing it on other
social media sites.
And I mean, and stories about this
story were still available.
Like now it's not just this New York
Post story, but now there's lots of
stories in other places
about the action Twitter and
Facebook took against this story.
So there was actually more attention
paid to this than there would have
been otherwise.
Yeah. I mean, before, because New
York Post, the New York
Post Twitter account got suspended
for a while. But briefly,
you know, one of the biggest stories
on Twitter was the New York Post
follow up about being banned
from Twitter.
But yeah, so I asked for this book.
I asked specifically people
at Facebook.
So what goes into the decision to do
this? And it's pretty
clear to me they rely on cues from
people in positions of authority and
in the government and mainstream
media institutions.
So when you have, you know, the New
York Times and The Washington Post
and all the CNN talking heads,
shrieking at you that that
the, you know, Facebook is evil.
Facebook, allowing
this misinformation to be out there
is is is
ruining our elections and these
companies should be destroyed.
They should be regulated out of
existence or broken up or whatever
because they allow this kind of
thing. Well, of course, the
companies are terrified, so they're
scared into making some bad
decisions, some bad calls.
But what are we going to do if
we got it, then you would just have.
And this is my argument to sort of
like right leaning people.
But then if you do punish these
companies, if you give that, if you
give them what the government wants,
what the what the Biden
administration wants, what the New
York Times wants, then you're just
left with those institutions that
are brutally honest, far
more hostile to a
to a conservative worldview
than Facebook is.
Facebook isn't hostile as an
as an institution.
It's a very important platform
for non-liberal views.
Yeah, I was going to I mean, it
seems, I guess, non-controversial
to say that the people who work at
Facebook really hate Donald Trump
and conservative Republicans.
But the platform that you know, the
the kind of coral
reef that is
Facebook allows these
fish to generally swam and
do extremely well.
Yeah. Why are conservatives so
convinced that, you
know, social media is against them
when you know, it seems
unquestionable that social media
was not responsible for,
but it definitely enabled Donald
Trump's rise.
I think they're missing the forest
for the trees. I think they're
seeing a couple truly
irritating moderation decisions
that we are again, it's fine to talk
about, fine to complain about them,
but are missing the fact that
at any given moment, the top 10
articles on Facebook are something
like from Fox News, Breitbart,
Ben Shapiro and so on.
And so they're killing it on social
media. They need social media.
It's good. It's been good for
and on YouTube.
A lot of very far left progressive
content has done really well,
just outside the kind of
confines of what the mainstream
media, all that they want
you to discuss. This limited
worldview that has existed for a
long time and is now fragmented is
now there. Gatekeeping role is over
because of social media and a lot of
us who don't fall into that narrow
category, which includes
libertarians to a great degree,
conservatives, some interesting
people on the left.
We should be happy that that
gatekeeping role is over.
It's much better for us.
It is kind of interesting that,
you know, this happened with movies
about, you know, at a certain point
when movies were being supplanted by
television.
Suddenly, you saw a lot of movies
about how evil television was.
The effects of TV are bad.
Sure, there were radio plays,.
Newspapers, so
my book has so many examples of
the New York Times, and I pick on
them a lot. But just inveighing
against the harm of,
you know, everything from the
phonograph to the radio
out what a car radio is, you can
have radios in your car.
It's just been the end of the world
if you can get your source of
information from something other
than us.
So this is and this is an industry
fight. Their social media is this
upstart rival and they are.
They are, they are attacking
them for that reason.
And we should be really clear eyed
about that
By the same token. Another story
that came out about the kind of
larger Facebook
penumbra is that Facebook
was maintaining separate
kind of rules for what were
what was typically talked about in
newspapers as elites.
But it turned out that
there were hundreds of thousands
of people, if not more, who were
whitelisted in some
way where they were able to do and
say things that would have gotten
lesser people bumped.
What do you think about that, or the
idea that Facebook presents itself
and social media in general presents
itself as this fabulously
flat new world?
You know, the old promise of
cyberspace in the 90s that
anybody from anywhere had the same
voice on, you know, on the internet,
nobody knows you're a dog.
Nobody knows if you are a Harvard
Ph.D. or if you're like somebody
living in your mother's basement.
And it turns out that's not true.
What do you think about that or how
how should we be factoring that into
the way we talk about social media?
I think we have to get used to the
idea that moderation is always going
to look unfair because
they're not moderating, they're not
approving this content before it
goes on they're.
You know, this happens so much where
there's two videos or two users
or two to what things we can
compare. And one gets
taken down or banned or some kind of
moderation decision is made.
The other thing is still there, and
we all know people who care about
fairness go, why is this thing
gone? When this thing is viral
is much more obviously violating the
policy.
That's because no one flagged that.
Yet no one complained it will.
There's just so much content and
they're doing it after someone
reports it or an algorithm flagged
it or something like that.
So it will always be the case
that that it looks uneven
or unequal because it will be.
And there's just too much.
There's too much content.
So they're going to have to the
platforms have to.
Have you know, these kind of
ins insufficient or irritating
rules that will always result
in in disparate impacts, but
there's just no other way to do that
unless you want to go to a model and
you know, you mentioned 230 and that
this would be the model if you got
rid of 230 where the platforms
have much greater liability.
Yeah, let's talk about that in terms
of Section 230.
It's a it's a good bridge into it.
Section 230 in
immunizes most
social media platforms and websites
from user generated
content. So if you're Yelp and
somebody says, you know, this
restaurant is the worst
restaurant of all time in the person
you know is, you know, pizzas, dogs
or something like that, Yelp doesn't
get in trouble.
The individual commenter might,
if you can find them or something
like that. The other thing it does
is it allows websites to
moderate content as they
see fit.
What is, you know, why
are people again on the right
and the left? Why are they so pissed
off about Section 230, where this
kind of obscure,
you know, code in a 1996
massive telecommunications
bill?
You know, why is Section 230 such
a flashpoint?
Yeah, it's funny because again,
both sides really want to get
rid of this law, but for different
reasons.
Conservatives have this idea that
the law and mistaken idea
that this law either already
or should
prevent politically motivated
or unfair moderation, that there's
some that they're supposed to be
neutral platforms.
So if they're moderating content in
a way that is not politically
neutral, they're no longer entitled
to Section 230 protection.
That's what many on the right are
saying, it's not the case.
There is no requirement for
neutrality.
I mean, if you want to make an
argument
that there should be a requirement
for neutrality, that's a different
matter. Josh Hawley has
advocated that.
But then you're starting to get
into. Well, so there will be a panel
of government people
to decide if your platform
is sufficiently neutral.
This would be a Senate proposal.
So as the Senate would convene such
a panel, why would the Democratic
controlled Senate, a
Democratic controlled Senate panel,
for deciding whether Facebook is
sufficiently neutral?
And that's going to benefit
conservatives, how there's just
there's like we're missing step two
in so many of
the, you know, on the
right. In particular, there's always
the conversation about shadow
banning that somehow it's
not that Twitter or Facebook is
just, you know, completely blocking
somebody or they've kicked them off
the platform. It's like they've
reduced the reach and the influence.
Is there any actual evidence of
that?
I think they do that sometimes,
but a lot of times when people say,
I've been shadow banned and you say,
What do you mean by that and say,
Well,
yeah, my content's not showing up in
people's feeds, but it just it
no, what happens is that this person
hasn't been looking at you.
You'll get into a phase where you're
seeing more content from a handful
of users because you have a high
level of engagement with their
content. The platform knows how long
you spend looking at people's posts,
and then it's trying to give you
more of that kind of relevant
information.
So we'll just so happened because
you've clicked around or something.
Some people's content will fall out
for a while and then it can come
back. So a lot of what gets
construed as shadow banning is
is not it's not taking place.
So it's just kind of ebbs
and flows of, you know, whether or
not your stuff is interesting to
people.
Yeah, or ebbs and flows and what
what's happened to be at the top
when I turn on my Twitter feed?
Maybe it's something from my
colleague Christian Bruschi, and it
just happened to be the first thing
I saw.
And then I like and favorite it, and
maybe I make a comment.
So then maybe next time I'm on
Twitter, it's going to show me a
Christian risky thing too.
And so now I'm suddenly seeing less
content from from Eric
Bay, my other colleague, just
because it's not nefarious.
Twitter's not trying to hide Eric
from. Right?
That's just what happens.
Well, what is the left critique of
Section 230?
The left critique is that social
media has allowed too much
bad speech, so they're making the
opposite argument.
Conservatives are saying not enough.
Our speech is being too aggressively
silenced, and the left is saying
they should aggressively silence
these people more.
Section 230 shields
the companies from some of the
consequences of having provocative
speech, so we should get rid of that
so that they will purge more bad,
provocative speech.
We don't like, so they're correct
that do it like they're tactically.
Yeah, they're on absolutely solid
ground that it would be worse for
conservatives, for non liberals if
you got rid of Section 230.
It makes perfect sense why Elizabeth
Warren hates the statute from her
worldview and from what her
political goals.
It doesn't make sense that Donald
Trump and Josh Hawley support it,
too.
What's wrong with liberals
or progressives saying,
You know what, Twitter, you know,
you should. You should mirror
our vision of the world and you
should shut down people like you
have the right to shut down people.
Why don't you narrow the scope of
acceptable discourse?
Well, I think that if this is
political figures saying this,
that actually raises a censorship
issue, I mean, the idea that the the
Senate is going to Hawley and
they've done this, how many times
now they're going to hall Mark
Zuckerberg and Jack Dorsey
and everyone else in front of
Congress?
Well, now at least they just have
to. Moved from one room in their
mansion to another, right hook up a
Zoom camera.
But these these hearings are always
such a farce.
Anyone who has ever watched them
comes away should come
away with
huge doubts that our regulators,
our elected officials who are in
their 80s, have any idea
how this technology works have the
smallest, the slightest clue to
regulate it in an informed way.
But so no, I find that I find that
authoritarian and illiberal and
wrong that Facebook does
something wrong or someone is
allowed to say something on Facebook
and they don't do anything about it
quickly enough for Elizabeth Warren
or whoever else, and they're going
to be summoned to Congress to
apologize for it.
It's ridiculous that actually we
should fight against because that's
wrong.
Was Facebook. Is Facebook implicated
in the genocide of the Rohingya?
This is one of the stories that
comes up again and again, because
when social media as a concept
or as a reality emerged in the late
aughts, it was celebrated,
you know, both Facebook and Twitter.
Early on, they helped
foment the Arab Spring.
You know, they helped. All the color
revolutions were carried
via Twitter.
You know, are they responsible for
bad things happening?
That's a good question.
They certainly have facilitated
some bad things happening, including
what you're describing,
the kind of the second half of my
book when I get away from some of
the sort of political speech and
addictiveness those topics, you
know, I'm trying to be a reasonable
person. I think preventing violence
is a legitimate function
of the government.
I see more
more leeway for for direct
government action.
If you're if you're trying to
address a problem of like genocide
happening or if social media is
fueling racial violence, then sure.
But then we have to be careful.
Well, is that actually what's going
on in?
Many of these questions are very
hard. So with with the Rohingya, for
instance, Myanmar, this was the
legitimate military
government of the country that
is using Facebook
to to inspire attacks
on the Rohingya.
So they shouldn't
they shouldn't allow that.
But now you're saying like, this
wasn't a rebel group, this wasn't.
This was the legitimate state
government. So I mean, there are
state actors in our own country who
sheriff's departments who exercise
violence in ways a lot of people are
not comfortable should Facebook
start shutting those down.
There's something about being the
official government of the country,
right, that maybe they
should be allowed to be on social
media, but then maybe they're not.
If they're advocates like it ends up
being kind of a not obvious
call for, you know, if you're going
to have a blanket policy.
Well, this comes back to, you know,
the fact that there's a number of
authoritarian leaders who
are still on Twitter, whereas Trump
is not.
And what you're saying is that it's
kind of a complicated call.
It is a complicated call because you
can obviously make a case that know
all these people should be.
These platforms should kick them
out. You could probably even make an
argument that the government could
require them to be kicked off
because they're they're they're
advocating for violence.
But then it starts to get it starts
to get tricky.
These and also these platforms are
used by people to be aware of these
threats of violence.
You know, the more we leave people
in the dark in these countries
where, where, where things like
Facebook are important sources of
information.
Also, you have the issue where
terrorist plots, threats of violence
that are made on social media are
organized through social media are
much more likely to fail.
There is a sense in which we want
all of our terrorists to be very
online, to be to be very
public about, you know, posting
selfies as they're having these
meetings. Because then they're then
they're much easily tracked down by
law, much more easily tracked down
by law enforcement.
A couple of states have passed laws
that would defang or change
kind of Section 230 or change
the ability of platforms
to do moderation.
And so one was passed in Florida,
which became law and is
currently under federal review.
So it's not happening
in Texas.
There was a law that passed what was
in that and do you think it's going
to hold up and is it going to
achieve any of its purposes?
No, because there were exemptions
to in clause four, except where
federal law is applicable.
Well, that's that's Section 230.
So they're going to they're going
to, you know, they're going to run
up against the fact that
even without Section 230, the
First Amendment conveys
a considerable protection
to private entities to set their own
speech related policies.
At the end of the day.
That's what this is. I know they're
big companies.
I know to some extent they're
functioning like they're the public
square, but they still are private
companies that that make a profit
from selling ads would
and and there is a powerful
bulwark against
the government intervening to tell
them what to do on speech related
grounds and
particularly to compel speech by
saying No, you have to, you have to
carry. Donald Trump, it's
one of the most litigated, honestly.
I mean, the First Amendment right is
one of one of the more ironclad
elements of our of our Constitution.
Our Supreme Court is extremely pro
free speech in a in a you
can you get to do whatever we can't
tell you.
Private entity, what to do sort of
way now.
That is definitely true.
But people like Clarence Thomas,
who is generally considered
pretty good on the First Amendment,
pretty good on, you know,
on limiting government.
He has said in various conversations
or in rulings or,
you know, comments on rulings
that actually, you know, maybe it's
time to start thinking about social
media.
You know, Facebook, Twitter at all,
not as public squares, but as common
carriers, which then would be
regulated. Because if you're a
common carrier, you don't have the
right to say who can use your
your service
or what they can do on it.
Kind of like a phone company that
AT&T back in the day
when it was a government enabled
monopoly couldn't say, No, you can't
have a phone, Robby because I don't
like your politics or if you had a
phone, they couldn't say, we're
going to bleep your speech.
If you start saying something, we
don't agree, right?
You know, are these services?
You know, this is where people go to
talk about shit.
But are they actual common carriers?
Yeah. And I think if Clarence Thomas
was, he would rule that way.
Yeah, I haven't seen a lot of
evidence that that the other that
he's speaking for a view supported
by a majority of the court
people like Richard Epstein,
who has a podcast that Hoover
Institution called the Libertarian,
you know, has said as much this that
they should be regulated as.
These platforms are just still very
different from the phone.
Again, they're selling ads, they're
selling a curated experience
for their users.
One they think their users want,
but they're relying on feedback from
their users.
They're analyzing what you're doing
and they're they're selling
a product in
a in a different way than it's
unique to them, in a way that wasn't
true for the phone companies.
And also, you know, you still
OK. Even if we decided they're
public utilities, it's like you have
some right to be there.
Like there's still there's still
rules and like you can get thrown
out, you can train as a public
utility, you get thrown off for
saying insane things, right?
You there's not some just
for talking in the quiet car on
Amtrak, right?
Yeah, right. That's but that's a
sensible rule. I good if you're in
the quiet car when I'm in there and
you're on your phone, yes, they
should throw you off.
Like, we support that.
So ever in so many of these cases,
you'll hear from people who say
they're absolutist.
No, we don't want moderation.
We just, you know, why are they
kicking off people?
They shouldn't do this.
But then you start having a
conversation about where we all
think some level of harassing
bullying
on a graphic that kind of.
Well, no, we don't want any of that
that goes, OK, well, then you start.
Get it. Well, what's up when
you get it gets thornier.
When you start looking at if you had
a panel of people to decide,
there would be disagreements about
what they think is.
Well, obviously we're going to leave
that up. But oh no.
Obviously, when we said we don't
want speech moderator, we don't want
things taken down or censored, well,
we didn't mean that we want back on.
So it's true.
So if that argument tense and
my kind of thinking and I
might be wrong about this, but that
tends to come more from the right,
from conservatives and maybe some
libertarians or people who claim
that mantle on the left.
There's a big, you know, big big
talk about using
antitrust to break these
companies up because there is
something awful and evil
about Facebook owning Instagram
and WhatsApp.
You know, it's just too big and you
know, it's squelching innovation.
It's doing this. It's doing that.
What what is the status of
actual attempts to break up, say,
Facebook, in particular through
antitrust legislation?
The problem that they run into is
that there's not a lot of a
rationale in existing antitrust
law for breaking up these
companies because that they're
just big and they have too much
power. And maybe they're unfair to
competitors, right?
There's nothing in existing
antitrust that bars you
from being unfair to a competitor.
The theory of antitrust is there is
harm to the consumer.
You know, the idea that one
company comes to dominate some
important market and then because
you can't get this service anywhere
else, they could raise the price of
it because they're not competing and
they could punish you, the consumer.
Well, that's obviously not what's
happening with social media because
we're talking about free services in
a lot of cases.
And also, they're not.
They do compete in a variety of
services. Facebook as a
place for political conversation,
just conversations in general to
happen is competing with Twitter
as a political ad service.
It's competing with Google as a
place where you post your pictures.
It's I guess it's pretty unrivaled,
but who cares? They're not charging
you for the service. It doesn't
matter. They're competing with your
old photo books, right?
It's not.
So they're not.
They're not monopolies for any one
thing.
If your view is, you know, you're
someone on the left and you just
don't like the idea of big companies
in general,
which is, I mean, literally the
right, the argument, right?
It's coming out of Louis Brandeis
and people like Elizabeth Warren and
Columbia Law Professor Tim Wu,
whose latest book is called The
Curse of Bigness, which is a
reference to Brandeis.
What's wrong with saying, you know
what, these companies these are just
too big, like they really
are really big, and that's not good.
Yeah, as long as it's not,
it's not. It doesn't seem to me to
be having any obvious massive
harm to customers, to the consumers
of these, the users of these
companies. In fact, most of them
seem to really like the product
like Google. Google is probably the
closest to a traditional monopoly
that it really is has very little
competition in its core search
engine function, right?
But that's because everybody likes
that search engine the best and
would use it.
They're not charging you for it.
They're they're, you know, maybe if
they if they started charging you
for it and they had no competition,
you could make some traditional
antitrust argument.
But right now, it's just the one
everyone wants,
and it's probably something else
could come. It's not inconceivable.
So many people have a failure of
imagination. They think these
companies are entrenched and they
could never on their own, you know,
come to meet their end.
Even though we've seen turnover
for for what the top 20 internet
companies are just over and over
and over again.
So I don't take that view at all.
If you want to say we need to do.
I'm trying to be reasonable.
You're saying we need to do
something.
OK, but why do we need to do
something and then they don't have a
very good argument for that other
than we just don't like bigness.
Well, we did.
It's just too much concentrated.
Philosophically, I just don't I
don't share that concern.
I'm not seeing what the harm to us
is.
What do you say about
arguments and Elizabeth Warren is,
you know, is a common thread in this
breaking up a company like Amazon
"Would be an umpire.
Or you can own a team, but
you can't do both at the same time.
So let's break-up, Amazon."
We're doing something to Amazon
because Amazon is such
a big company and Amazon is using
the data it gets from
its users to sell its own version
of goods.
You know, this is a big complaint of
hers that you can either be a
marketplace or you can
be the seller, you
know, a fair and neutral
marketplace, or you can be
the seller of your own stuff.
But the idea of Amazon basics,
you know, cheap kind of, you know,
basic, you know,
things, commodities or, you know,
you know, everything from cords to
certain types of clothing they sell
on Amazon Basics line, and they
have an unfair advantage over
the branded products
that they're selling.
Why is she wrong to be concerned
about?
I think she must be living on
another planet.
This is the greatest service ever.
You can easily find
things you need that make your life
better and pay a very reasonable
amount of money for them and have
them show up at the next day on your
doorstep.
This is this is fantastic.
This is amazing, especially during
after the last year and a half, we
just went through the pandemic right
when we were told, Don't go,
don't congregate with other people,
don't avoid excess socialization.
Stay in your home citizen.
This kind of really thing I found
very awful.
Social media has made this so much
easier. You didn't even have to go
to the grocery store anymore.
It can show up the things you
need can show up on your doorstep
with, like the click of several
buttons. This is a good thing.
I don't again, the harm to the
consumer is non-existent.
This is something that is great.
This is a good service that people
love. People love it.
More than the Amazon's
approval ratings are higher
than Congress, and that's true
actually of most social media
companies. So rather than
Congress break up Big Tech, maybe
Big Tech should break up Congress.
That would be the version that the
American public would actually
support.
Right? You have a chapter in the
book Cancel Culture and Harassment.
Let's talk a little bit about that.
How do you define cancel culture
and is is it a real
thing or in what way is that a real
thing? Because, you know, part of
the backdrop is that more people
have more access to, you know,
ways of expressing their opinions
and reading other people's opinions.
So, you know, certainly compared to
even 20 years ago, but certainly
something like 50 years ago, you
know, you can just you can say what
you want and kind of.
You know, call it to people's
attention.
So how does how do things like
cancel culture and harassment come
into that kind of backdrop?
Yeah, the the rise of social media
has made it easier to
criticize people and hold people
accountable in a lot of ways that
are good.
It has also had the effect of
you can criticize and hold people
accountable to a degree.
You probably don't need to and that
they don't deserve it.
People who are not public figures,
you know, so much of our speech
takes place in text or
video or is recorded
or preserved in some way,
including speech from when you're a
young person. I feel lucky
to have know finished high school
before the era of smartphones,
where everything I young people say
and do is saved forever
and is out there and is lurking
to to ruin your life at a bad
moment, maybe 10 or 20 years later,
it really is horrible.
What what can happen to people
when it turns out you said something
sexist or racist or homophobic when
you were 13, something that
everyone on the planet has done.
If we're holding people to this
level of accountability, no one
would ever be able to get a new job
or get admitted to college ever
again.
But social media has allowed this to
happen, and I do.
I think it is a serious problem.
I write a lot about it how we're
becoming very unfair, particularly
to young people, to nonpublic
people.
And I do.
Social media is responsible for that
to some degree.
Now there's there's not a very
satisfying way to like, put
this genie back in the bottle.
I advocate for different norms
of just how we conduct ourselves
have different norms of journalism.
I think it kind of
lay those out like, what?
How you know, how should we treat
somebody, you know, the
Teen Vogue, you know, a very
left-leaning Condé Nast web
only publication.
After going through a couple of
things, they named a new
editor who was a young
African-American woman.
And then it turned out she got
canceled very quickly because it
turned out when she was in high
school, she had made a bunch
of anti-gay jokes or,
you know, jokes at the expense of
gay people as well as Asians.
So she got, canned
you know how?
What's the different norm that is?
I mean, is that good and fair?
Or is that.
No, its stupid and bad and wrong and
they should not do that. She
apologized and it was a long time
ago, and that ought to be good
enough. It ought to be good enough
in all those circumstances.
No one can survive that level of
scrutiny. Actually, one of the
leading people who is trying to get
her in trouble, well, then it turned
out that, of course, that person had
also tweeted.
And then when you get that person in
trouble, the person, that person who
got that person in trouble will also
say that this
is the way of the world.
Yeah, you know, and we just need to
disengage from this.
Journalists need to practice
different norms. I become more
cognizant of the amount
of harassment and cruelty
you can inflict on someone by naming
them in a story.
So let's be more thoughtful about
whether this really matters.
If you if you're gonna write a
profile of someone you know you're a
local hometown hero, I mean, that
story had that up.
So the football guy who had the
Venmo me beer money and then
they do a profile of him and the
local reporter looks up his old
tweets. Why don't do that?
That's a new normal journalism.
But that had that had
a good ending because the
journalists,.
The journalists got fired after they
because they looked at his tweet,
Yeah, we need to stop that.
No more of that.
OK, so this is like the Greek
play
in the Austria, where it's like
you just have to at a certain point,
you have to say, OK, we're no longer
just kind of having a cycle of
vengeance, we're stopping the
killing and we're just going to have
something approaching justice, yeah,
I think social media sites should
also be very cognizant
of letting
people.
I mean, they have policies against
harassment, doxing,
revenge porn.
This is, you know, these are serious
subjects in which you might you
could probably make a case for some
kind of law or narrowly tailored fix
to Section 230 that requires them
actually to take down some of this
content. You know, in the trade off
between, you know, privacy and
free speech are both things we want
to protect. And then sometimes they
do butt heads a little bit and I am
actually a libertarian.
I don't know, maybe more inclined
than others. I don't know to
actually, even though I'm a free
speech absolutist, there are some
cases where I will. I will default
in favor of privacy.
So to the extent that there's
some need for the government to do
something on those front, I can
see a way for that.
I'm interested, for instance, with.
Yeah, there are some statues of some
local laws against revenge porn.
I think you could treat it.
You know, this is publishing
people's intimate images without
their permission.
You could treat it like copyright
infringement. You know, you get a
takedown request, a site gets a
takedown request if you're
infringing copyright and then you
get a period of time to take it
down. So it's not like you're
instantly liable.
The second, you know, you have no
control over it and this just
happens and then you're in trouble.
Something like that seems reasonable
to me.
There are a couple of cases where
technology the new technology
has will force us to consider
things of this nature, and I
think that's reasonable.
Talk a little bit about how you came
to be a libertarian,.
How I came to be?
Yeah, yeah. What's your origin
story?
You know, radioactive.
spider,
Milton, Rose, Friedman, bit you on
the arm.
Yeah, that's man that was.
Wouldn't that be the story?
No, I I think I was.
I came from a Republican household,
but my parents were basically
libertarians, you know, very
about low
taxes, low regulation.
But, you know, leave everybody
alone. And seeing that
that that was that
made. That was consistent.
I think it's the consistency that
brought me in a lot of people I know
to libertarianism that you have one
party or at the time, do you know
when I was growing up, nineties
aughts? You have one party saying,
Yeah, the government's not should be
less involved in your finances, but
it should be more involved in the
bedroom and overseas and in all
these other ways.
And then the other party is saying
the opposite thing.
Well, now where we really want
government to leave you alone in
your own decisions and not be
harassed by the police, and
we're not gonna try to destroy
either. But, but yes, we want
more of your money and to tell you
how to spend it and just the
way you, you, you solve those,
those inconsistencies is to become a
libertarian. So I did.
Yeah. I mean, do you is your pension
for kind of consistency, do you
think that's just like temperamental
or does you know or
did you pick that up somewhere?
I used to think everyone
has this inner drive to seek this
consistency, and this was the best
argument libertarianism had going
for it. I actually think now
people are not as motivated by
consistency as I used to think
because I used to think this was
always a slam dunk argument.
When I'm arguing for libertarianism,
I said, Well, you think this?
What about this?
I mean, have you seen that meme?
You know the face just saying "yes."
Yeah, it's right.
It's people are are happy
to kind of. Or at least some of the
people engaged in ideas
on the right and the left, I think,
are just like perfectly happy to
revel in their own hypocrisies on
these things and say, "No, we're not
doing your thing where no one is in
control of anyone's lives." Or maybe
that sounds good in theory, but our
enemies are going to win that way
and they're going to be in control.
So we need to be in control like
they're, you know, they've got the
ring and they're saying it's a this
is a gift. Let Gondor use it.
That's everyone in this conversation
these days. And that's and that's a
problem for liberty, because we're
just saying this has gone wrong.
So many times, of course, is going
to be no better with you in charge.
Why do you have any
thought to that?
This will this will this will work
out this time.
Are you optimistic
for libertarian ideas
on some levels?
You know, on many profound levels,
it seems like, you know, just
not a very libertarian time.
Government spending is massive,
government debt is massive control
of our, you know, whether we're
wearing masks or what documents
we have to show in order to go to a
bar or, you know, a restaurant.
On the other hand, you know,
foreign policy seems to be in a
place that is more
noninterventionist, which is a kind
of traditional libertarian thing.
You know, gay marriage or marriage
equality, drug legalization,
positive views towards immigration
seem to be on the upswing.
And we have a lot of these
technologies that are allowing us to
live how we want on
our own terms.
You know, what do you think would
sum up the current environment?
The I think we should be clear eyed
about the pandemic and pandemic
restrictions, that this has been a I
agree with Joe Jorgensen, our
Libertarian Party candidate, who
said this is like a just
unbelievable, vast
expansion of government policy
that I wouldn't have even
necessarily guessed that so many
Americans would go along with it.
I mean, now you have and
our political elites are, they're
reveling in their hypocrisy.
They how many mayors
get to be caught at the third
jazz club of the night unmasked
while you the citizen, you the
citizen should be.
Actually, you should wrap a mask,
two layers of mask around your
child, your screaming child before
you get them into the school.
I think it is.
It is horrible the amount
of restrictions we have said it
is OK, the amount of arbitrary,
capricious the government can tell
you what to do at all times, and
it's for your own good and you can't
question it.
So that's the bad and it is very,
very bad. Don't get me wrong, but
it is better actually, that we
that this is happening at a time
where we do have social media
the way that there is so many ways
to complain about this and to
discuss this, the media is
the biggest cheerleader.
The mainstream media is the biggest
cheerleader of permanent pandemic
restrictions on our lives that has
that would have ever existed.
I can you imagine if this
is happening and we have no way
to discuss, to express opposition,
to have conversations with people
who are skeptical of this, except
for CNN
and your local newspaper, the New
York Times, the know the people
who are just going to reflect the
preferences of the Biden
administration or of lawmakers
in general. That would be a lot
worse. So social media
is is is we
should leave it as this free,
uninhibited, free wheeling space
where the conversation is sometimes
messy. Sometimes people say things
that are wrong or that are scary or
that we don't agree with.
But it is still so much better
to have this open ended conversation
than to to go back to an
era where a small
number of people with a very
limited, very wrong.
Worldview had complete control of
the conversation.
How worried should we be that it's
sometimes social media companies?
I mean, this started and I guess
twenty eighteen, but Facebook,
Twitter, Apple
at various points, Tim Cook
said, You know, the tech industry
is out of control and we welcome
regulation. Facebook is running ads
saying, You know what?
You know, internet regulations
haven't really changed since 1996,
when the Communications Decency Act
passed. You know,
obviously they need to be updated
and they're angling for that.
How how implicated in
whatever is happening are the
companies themselves.
Yeah, Facebook is all all on board
with making these changes.
These changes that will be
shepherded, shepherded into law
by by the revolving door of people
who go from media to Facebook to
to the White House and so on
and so forth.
Actually, Twitter doesn't want to
change a lot of these laws because
they rightly view themselves as a
smaller competitor.
And if you if you made
policies that social media sites
have to do more moderation, while
Facebook can handle that just the
way Walmart doesn't mind if you
raise minimum wage because you put
all their competitors out of
business first, it's a very similar
dynamic. It's it's actually a very
self, a parent, one to libertarians
or free market conservative type
people.
I also think to some extent, maybe
Facebook and the other social media
sites are just saying they want to
go along with regulation.
But then what does that actually
look like? You know they want to.
We're open to it. We're open to it.
The right regulation when we hadn't
had input on and made sure was not
the bad one that we didn't want.
So there's there's a certain amount
of cynicism I take with,
you know, the subtitle of tech panic
is why we shouldn't fear Facebook,
which we've talked about and we
shouldn't fear the future.
How do we get past the kind of panic
stage with social media
or with Big Tech right now?
What what?
What are the ways that we can kind
of moderate, you know, people's
visceral reactions
people need to train themselves
to just like not believe what the
media is saying about any of these
things? I really the mainstream
media is the villain of this book
and is the villain of so much that's
going on that the
narrative that they advance that
everything new is scary and
dangerous because it competes with
them.
Yeah, they clubhouse the this
popular audio
kind of group social
media app that was really
briefly popular during the pandemic
because it was a way to chat with
people. Know The New York Times
has this just absurd coverage
of this thing like, well, what if
it's not going to recorded?
So what if people are saying
they can say whatever they
want to say, whatever they want is a
fact check end of the world like
that kind of that is moral panic.
And it has been the bread and butter
of newspapers of local
television of, you know,
what are your what are your
neighbors doing its be afraid for
your children, that kind of thing.
That's why I call it a panic.
And, you know, and all
of that, so many of those in the
past have turned out to be
nothing to them from from
video games to to the radio
to the, you know to the New York
Times said, I found
the book. The New York Times said
Alexander Graham Bell should be hung
from the neck until dead because,
well, now people can be calling each
other all the time. This would be
the end of the world as we know it.
We got to really train ourselves
to not fall for that kind of thing.
That's a good point to leave it on.
Robby Soave of Reason.
Thanks for talking to Reason.
The newest book is Tech Panic
Why We Shouldn't Fear Facebook
and the Future.
Thank you.